In the last lecture I set
the terms for the week's
discussion, those being
retrenchment and political
advancement. I wanted
to make clear on Monday's
lecture that the Scottsboro
Boys and the Black Cabinet
represent two ends of a
spectrum of political
possibilities of black
America in the 1930s. They
are together
articulating a new voice,
a new vehicle to
communicate responses to and
articulations of
possibilities,
but coming from very
different places in very
different ways. The
Scottsboro Boys reaches back
to a past of social
control, certainly,
but also representing in
the Scottsboro Boys case,
in the way the Communist
Party gets involved,
that there's a new mentality
at work in black America,
and new values
in--or being seen--the,
the, the accused being
seen as commodities on a
political battlefield.
And the Black Cabinet
represented the best
possible world of new
political insiderism
at the national level,
in a different way
than the Scottsboro Boys,
serving as important symbols
of blacks' centrality to the
political realm. Now I
wanted to continue the
discussion along those
lines and to--these--I'm
sorry--these are the themes
for this week. I want to
continue the discussion
along these lines,
but focusing upon the
National Negro Congress,
the Marian Anderson
Easter Sunday Concert,
and the March on Washington
movement. This--the events
for this lecture are
essentially the second half
of the 1930s. But it's
important to realize,
the things I was talking
about in Monday's lecture
are overlapping, many of
the events I'm talking about
today. These are all
happening in the course of
the decade, but certainly at
some point all happening at
the same time. Let me start
with the National Negro
Congress. The National
Negro Congress--for some
reason, this is a lecture I
wrote down a lot of notes
for you guys, and I'm not
sure really why. Maybe I
was being generous. I
don't know. Anyway,
the National Negro Congress
has its start in the
National Industrial League.
It forms in 1933. This is a
response to the development
of, well, Franklin
Roosevelt's New Deal and
agencies like the
National Recovery--well,
an early incarnation, the
National Industrial Recovery
Act, and how this
organization was not going
to care about setting wage,
setting minimum wages for
agricultural workers or for
domestic workers. And two
men get together, Robert C.
Weaver and John P.
Davis, and start--black men,
and start testifying before
Congress, before
the Senate, saying,
you know, "This
is an abomination.
You're completely
wri--writing out or,
or disregarding those areas
that have the most important
or significant black
involvement." The Negro
Industrial League is
a two-man operation,
but they fashion themselves
as an umbrella group
representing black interests
across the country. It--It
exists pretty much only in
passing. Now the important
part of it is that Robert C.
Weaver is seen as
doing such a great job,
having recent--recently
received his J.D.
from Harvard, he gets
incorporated into the
federal government, and is
one of the very first race
advisors. So that's
where the Nation--the Negro
Industrial League is
important for bringing in
one of its own into the
federal bureaucracy. The
other person, John P.
Davis, remains an outsider,
and we'll be spending more
time on Davis's activities
in the course of this
lecture. Davis organizes,
in the wake of the Negro
Industrial
League's collapse,
the Joint Committee for
National Recovery. It lasts
only for two
years. It, too,
fashions itself as an
umbrella organization
representing blacks' needs
from across the country.
Now this is a
self-representation.
I mean these were not, you
do not--You do not have all
sorts of
black-run organizations,
running to John P.
Davis and the Joint
Committee for National
Recovery, which is
essentially him and an
office and a couple
of figurehead people.
Davis--well they
aren't running to Davis,
because one, this is a new
kid on the block basically.
They're still looking
at organizations like,
you know, churches,
business associations,
the NAACP, for example,
but the Joint Committee for
National Recovery does at
least one important thing
before it collapses, and it
organizes a conference at
Howard University. And
this is a conference that is
dedicated to trying to
understand the economic
plight of African Americans
during the Great Depression
and the New Deal. Now
it's just a conference,
but it brings--but it's
remarkable that it brings
together people from a
wide range of political
backgrounds. It brings
together labor organizers,
agricultural
workers, domestic workers,
you know, people who are
doing work on the ground.
It brings together
intellectuals like W.
E.
B.
Du Bois, who's becoming a
Marxist and talking economic
cooperatives
along race lines,
something actually in
some ways looking similar to
Booker T.
Washington's ideologies. It
brings together leaders of
the Communist Party,
the Workers' Party,
the Socialist Party. It
brings together people from
the federal
government, like Robert C.
Weaver now, all asking the
question: what is the status
of the Negro in, in the
New Deal? And the result of
this conference was--well,
many things came out of it.
One, scathing attack on
the New Deal for the way it
ignored blacks'
conditions on the ground,
in ways I outlined briefly
on Monday. It launched an
investigation into communist
activities at Howard
University, Howard
University then essentially
being funded by the
federal government,
and essentially now
still receiving most of its
support from the
federal government. An
investigation was
launched into the communist
activities at Howard,
and certainly there were
communists on the faculty
at Howard and certainly
socialists as well,
and certainly a lot of
sympathizers. So there was
an attempt to silence and
actually shut down the
university as a result of
this conference.
And most importantly,
it establishes a group
called the National Negro
Congress. I forgot
that slide. Okay,
those are the notes for
what I just told you. The
National Negro Congress
actually does turn into that
kind of umbrella
organization that the Negro
Industrial League and the
Joint Committee for National
Recovery all aspired to be.
The National Negro Congress
forms out of a call, I
mean the Howard University
Conference, "We
need to organize a,
a national
political action group,
and it becomes the
National Negro Congress,
formed in 1936. The
congress convenes for the
first time in
Chicago in '36,
where it's met where--with
police harassment,
due to alleged communistic,
communist participation. A.
Philip Randolph, who
we'll be talking about more
towards the end
of the lecture,
but for now, just to know
the most important--Bless
you.
The most important labor
leader in black America,
is elected its first
president. And the National
Negro Congress
establishes--sorry,
I'm all off on my slides
here today. Excuse me. It
establishes a slate that's
concerning civil rights,
women's rights,
labor's rights,
aid to farmers and
sharecroppers. It calls for
an anti-lynching law; it
calls for voting rights,
educational opportunities,
social and unemployment
insurance, and opposition
to war and fascism. Civil
rights, women's
rights, labor's rights,
aid to farmers
and sharecroppers,
anti-lynching
law, voting rights,
education opportunities,
social un--and unemployment
insurance and an oppression
to war and fascism. If you
think back to a few
weeks earlier in the course,
a large part of this slate
that the National Negro
Congress calls for is
identical to the slate,
to the manifesto, that the
Niagara Movement calls for
some thirty years earlier,
not quite thirty years. The
point is, a lot of the
issues haven't changed,
despite some real
changes in those thirty,
thirty-one years, excuse
me. Now the National Negro
Congress was not just made
up of black folks getting
together calling for a slate
of a progressive future. It
is, as the slide
up here indicates,
a cross section of black
groups and white labor,
of all different kinds
of groups as far as black
business bureaus,
black churches,
black labor organizations.
The congress actively courts
white labor in this regard,
especially the Congress of
Industrial Organization, and
it sets out this agenda for
change on the
ground. It has,
more than anything
else, a labor orientation,
despite even business groups
being involved. It's going
to change things on the
ground. And the person
organizing--sort of--A.
Philip Randolph
is the president,
but the person doing the
work on a day-to-day basis
is John P.
Davis. He was there at
the Negro Industrial League,
there at the Joint Committee
for National Recovery,
and he's really running the
National Negro Congress.
And he runs it for
the length of the NNC's
existence, which is not
quite a decade. Now one of
the first things the
Congress does successfully,
aside from just meeting, is
establish a Southern Negro
Youth Congress, essentially
the youth arm of the
Congress. The Southern
Negro Youth Con--Congress
had its inaugural conference
half a year late in
February, 1937 in
Richmond, Virginia,
and it makes its
headquarters there for a
number of years. With the
guidance of the Southern
Negro Youth
Conference leaders,
it becomes a permanent
organization and almost
immediately organizes five
thousand tobacco workers
into the Tobacco Stemmers
and Laborers Industrial
union. Very soon after, an
SNYC leads a sit-down strike
in--at a Virginia Tobacco
Company and garn--and,
and gets wage increases
of twenty to thirty-three
percent. This is
remarkable. The Southern
Negro Youth
Congress, these are,
these are people your age
and a little bit older,
going down to
Richmond, Virginia,
the heart of
the Confederacy,
and organizing black workers
into a union and getting
wages--wage increases for
them. It's nothing really
short of
astonishing. By 1939,
when the third annual
conference of the SNYC
gathers in Birm--gathers,
they meet in Birmingham,
Alabama. Over six
hundred delegates are in
attendance. It's the
largest conference to date.
The themes of the conference
revolved around citizenship,
equal opportunity,
and black culture.
These are themes that by now
must be familiar to all of
you. I've been talking
about it during this course,
after all. Again, themes
from the Niagara Movement,
but in this case
with the students,
a different type of cultural
emphasis. I think a
hangover, in a sense, from
the Harlem Renaissance. But
the Southern Negro Youth
Congress was not another
middle-class black
venture. I'm thinking,
too, that's sort of the
cultural producers of the
Renaissance. It espoused
a democratic socialist
vision. It was militantly
interracial. It offered its
full support to the Congress
Industrial Organization,
that breakaway set of
labor unions that actually
welcomed black workers.
And, this is the
most important part,
it's very quietly
Communist. The Southern
Negro Youth Congress
moves its headquarters from
Richmond down to Birmingham
and establishes a watchdog
presence in the Deep South.
It wages suffrage campaigns,
you know, trying to
get people to vote,
anti-poll tax campaigns.
It tries to fight against
police brutality. Now
the Southern Negro Youth
Congress is important
because of its Communist
involvement, certainly, but
also because you can see it
as a preface to the
civil rights activities that
defined Birmingham
some twenty years later,
and that as
we'll see next week,
you start seeing a lot of
these kinds of activities in
other places
throughout the South,
through other
organizations. Now I'll
ex--expand upon
this point later on.
It's very important.
The Southern Negro Youth
Congress is but one
example that forces,
if you think about it,
forces a re-periodization of
the Civil Rights Movement.
I'll leave that alone there
for a moment. Well, the
SNYC begins to fade as we
get into the 1940s. Its
male leaders go off to
fight; its female leaders
do not remain youthful. I
mean, neither do
the men of course,
but the women are still
at home. It's no longer a
"youth congress."
They're not regenerating
themselves. And the
whispering about its linkage
to the Communist Party
really prevents it from
becoming a major political
force after the Soviet-Nazi
pact in 1939, when the
Soviet--when Hitler and
Stalin get together, saying,
"We won't fight against each
other," which alienates
a lot of people who were
supporting the Communist
Party in the United
States.Meanwhile, back in
the National Negro Congress,
I'll roll back the clock
a few years. Randolph,
A.
Phil--A.
Philip Randolph,
he's the president,
is hearing more whispering
about Communist involvement
in the National
Negro Congress,
and he's not happy about
it. He fights--he denies it
at first, goes,
"No, we are, you know,
we are an independent
organization. Even though
we've modeled ourselves,
modeled ourselves after
Communist ideologies as
far as developing a Popular
Front of all people from
different kinds of places
coming together to
fight towards one goal,
we are not Communists." But
then it becomes clear that
Communists have infiltrated
the National Negro Congress,
mainly through the Congress
of Industrial Organization.
So white labor organizers,
Randolph concludes,
are bringing Communism
into this organization,
and he wants no
part of it. Randolph,
after denying
it for a while,
goes to the national
convention in 1940 where
he's going to stand up
in front of the Congress,
the National Negro
Congress and resign,
and resign with fire,
talking about how the
Communists do not have our
best interests at heart.
He's basically
booed off the stage.
I mean, the Communists are
now taking control of the
Negro Congress. And John P.
Davis, where is he
through all of this? Well,
he's--he's a
Communist actually. And so,
you know, he's caught in
a rock and a hard place,
but sides with the
Congress. And that's where
he, that's where he
continues to reside for a
handful more years.
Now that's in 1940,
and Randolph's about to
go off and start something
quite different in response
to his departure from the
Nation--National Negro
Congress. And we'll get to
that towards the end of the
lecture. While all of this
is going on--all of this
meaning the National Negro
Congress becoming organized,
having its conferences,
turning more towards
Communism and then Randolph
breaking from it--you have a
series of events happening
on the cultural front,
cultural and political
front, that sort of
galvanizes black opinion and
leads to a new set of
political possibilities,
and that's the Marian
Anderson Easter Sunday
concert in 1939.
Marian Anderson,
black woman, regarded as
one of the world's greatest
living contraltos.
She's--she sings opera. Her
case is well-known,
partly for her international
stature, partly for the
other high-profile whites
who are involved in it,
and partly for the symbolic
significance attached to the
controversy. Let me give
you the history behind
it, and the controversy,
and explain its
significance. Howard
University School of
Music had regularly been
scheduling Marian
Anders--Marian Anderson to
come back from Europe.
She was born in the U.S.
but couldn't establish a
career in the U.S. She goes
off to Europe and
becomes a fan--a,
a superstar in Europe.
But Howard School of Music
starts--is schedule--as her
star is rising in Europe,
is scheduling her to
come back to the U.S.
to give conf--concerts, and
they've been on campus. As
her popularity rises, they
can't house her on campus
any more, and
in 1936 and '37,
the Howard concert had been
moved to a local black high
school auditorium. By 1938,
Marian Anderson's fees are
such, and the
demand is such,
they need a larger venue in
order to spon--to hold the
concert. They went into the
black commercial district,
which is right
next to Howard,
went to a theater that was
bigger than the black high
school
auditorium, had it there.
In 1939, the
fees are greater,
the demand is greater.
Where are we going to have a
concert? The School of
Music goes to the Daughters
of the American Revolution,
the DAR. The Daughters of
the American Revolution,
a social political
organization--I think more
social in this moment until
it becomes politicized--of
women who can date back
their lineage to people who
fought in the Revolutionary
War. At that time and
really only until the last
ten or fifteen years, a very
white organization and very
conservative organization.
And they manage Constitution
Hall, which is the largest
venue in the city. It's
still there today. Well,
they go to the Daughters of
the American Revolution,
the School of Music does,
"We'd like to have Marian
Anderson performing in,
in Constitution Hall. Would
you let her sing there?"
Now the DAR maintained a
strictly segregated policy.
Now in D.C.
theaters, it was quite
common to have segregated
audiences. If
blacks were allowed in,
they'd only be allowed up in
the balcony. You could have
blacks on stage always,
because they "dance so well,
they "sing so beautifully"
as the stereotype goes. But
DAR was different: no blacks
in the audience period,
and no blacks on stage. It
was an all-white venue all
the time. The Howard
University School of Music,
rebuffed by this, goes to
a local white high school,
which has a much larger
auditorium than the black
high school that had been
used before and the Rialto,
and it's rebuffed
again. Black leaders in the
District then form the
Marian Anderson Citizens
Committee to fight these
decisions. It's a coalition
of local clergy, teachers,
civic and fraternal
organizations, trying to
basically knock down these
doors. Behind the
scenes, however,
a man named Charles Houston,
a lawyer at this point for
the NAACP--he's the first
general counsel. He had
been brought to Howard a
decade earlier to reorganize
its law school and starts
teaching the first civil
rights law
classes in the country,
the law school does.
Charles Houston gets
involved behind the scenes,
as well as the NAACP. They
start organizing
mass meetings,
letters of support start
being sent in to these
different organizations,
and they're focusing on the
white high school. They go
to--They're going to the,
the Board of Education.
The Board of
Education says, "Okay,
we'll, we'll come to a
compromise on this. We will
allow Marian Anderson to
perform at the white high
school, Central High.
We'll let it be integrated.
But this will be a one-time
event and you may
not use this"--you,
the citizens
organizing the committee,
and quietly, Charles
Houston--"you may not use
this as a precedent from
challenging separate but
equal educational systems in
the District of Columbia."
Well, the fact is, that's
what Houston was trying to
do the whole time,
once he got involved,
because this is a great way
to break down the color line
in the school system,
using Marian Anderson as a
symbolic vehicle. It's a
compromise the protestors
refused--refused to accept
and the School of Board
called their bluff
[laughs]--the Board of
Education called their
bluff. So the NAACP and
Charles Houston go to the
White House. They go to the
White House via
Mary McLeod Bethune,
talked about on Monday,
who gets them to have an
audience with
Eleanor Roosevelt;
Eleanor Roosevelt
who's a member of the DAR,
incredibly popular
syndicated-syndicated
columnist. Approaches
the DAR and they tell her,
"No, we're not
breaking this policy,
and she resigns in protest
and writes a very famous
column about this, and her
embarrassment for the DAR.
Eleanor Roosevelt
talks to Harold Ickes,
Secretary of the
Interior, himself,
like Eleanor Roosevelt,
considered a "friend of the
race," as what the phrase
was at the time. Harold
Ickes steps in and arranges
a concert on Easter Sunday
in 1939 for Marian Anderson
at the Lincoln Memorial. As
the Secretary
of the Interior,
he, he, he controlled the
federal land and controlled
what happened on the
National Mall. On the day
in question, Ickes steps
up to the microphone and
introduces Marian Anderson.
One prominent journal
remarked after
the fact that,
I'm quoting here, "The
brevity and force of his
speech was destined to
rival Lincoln's Gettysburg
Address." Now whether
that's true or not is
a--well I don't think
we remember this speech,
so it didn't really rival
the Gettysburg Address. But
it is short and it is
powerful. This is what he
says here, one excerpt
of what he says: "Genius,
like justice, is
blind. For Genius,
with the tip of her wings,
has touched this woman,
who, if it had not been for
the great mind of Jefferson,
if it had not been for
the great heart of Lincoln,
would not be able to stand
among us today as a free
individual in a
free land. Genius.
Genius draws no color line."
You start hearing a plane
flying overhead there. It
was something of a
circus atmosphere. He says,
"Genius, like justice,
is blind. For Genius has
touched with the tip of
her wings this woman,
who, if it had not been for
the great mind of Jefferson,
if it had not been for
the great heart of Lincoln,
would not be able to stand
among us today as a free
individual in a
free land. Genius.
Genius draws no color line."
It's a powerful statement
coming from a representative
of the federal government.
Now four hours before Ickes
steps to the microphone,
four hours before the
concert begins, people start
arriving at the National
Mall and the Lincoln
Memorial. And what they
find there is really
quite remarkable. D.C.
is a very segregated city
during this era. What they
find is an absence, an
absence of "colored only"
sections, an
absence of, you know,
"White section. No colored
allowed." Seventy-five
thousand people
crowd the Mall,
and it may not sound like a
dramatic number to you in
our day of, you know,
millions showing up at the
Mall, but this is historic.
And it's also opera,
which is not known as
the people's music,
right? Seventy-five
thousand people crowd the
Mall to hear
Anderson's performance,
and an untold number
of people listen to the
performance on radio
around the country,
aired live. Planes are
circling overhead trying to
understand the scene that's
going on there. This is a
famous image:
Marian Anderson,
long fur coat, singing
just with piano accompanying
her. Steps up to the
microphone and in a powerful
yet dignified
rebuke to the DAR,
Anderson simply
begins her concert in this
way:(singing) "My
country, 'tis of thee,
Sweet land of
liberty, of thee I sing;
She sounded a
bit like that,
maybe a bit
better. Eloquent,
powerful, subtle,
undeniable. She is in this
moment claiming the country
as much--It belongs as much
to her as it belongs to the
Daughters of the American
Revolution. Everybody there
got it. She didn't have to
say, you know, "I'm so
glad to be here today. It's
lovely. You know, D.C., how
are you?" You didn't have
to do that kind of
stuff; simply declared,
"This is my country
too." And in fact,
as an aside, it's--the
inauguration of Barack
Obama, something, I don't
know if I'll talk about it
or not at the
end of the class,
but when Aretha Franklin
stands up to sing "My
Country, 'Tis of
Thee"--she, I mean,
it's a, culturally a very
dense inauguration. I mean,
all inaugurations are
rich with symbolism,
but this one was rather
remarkable. She was singing
"My Country, 'Tis
of Thee," for the,
you know, that people would
get it in the audience,
but there's a whole other
level of understanding for
those people who know
this story and what Marian
Anderson did with this
particular exhortation. And
I, I've heard, if you
watched the HBO special the
day before the inauguration,
they explained some of
this. I didn't see it; but,
and many people didn't. The
significance of Aretha
Franklin's performance of
that particular song
was lost on many folks,
but it was a reckoning
back to this moment. The
moment's important,
not just because,
you know, it's a classy
way of being a civil rights
protestor, but it's
important for these
different reasons. With
Eleanor Roosevelt and Harold
Ickes giving their very
public support to the,
the Citizens Committee
for Marian Anderson,
and for the right for
her to sing at the DAR,
it suggests to African
Americans that the federal
government, at
the highest levels,
in the White House, "really
does care about us." They'd
been working on the Black
Cabinet. That's--They've
been going out and
changing things.
We're now as a group
beginning to vote for
Democrats anyway,
through--because of FDR.
And now the First Lady,
the Secretary of Interior,
are saying, "Genius draws
no color line." Of course,
it's the symbolism wrapped
up in performing under the
protective gaze of
the Great Emancipator.
That's not lost on anybody
either. But it's also felt
on the very local level in
ways that's lost to history
often.When I was
working on my first book,
my dissertation in fact, I
was interviewing a longtime
D.C.
resident. He was then about
eighty years old. And we
were just talking
about this era,
you know, in
Washington, D.C.,
and, and what it meant to be
black and struggle with the
color line. And
this concert comes up,
and he said something I've
never forgotten. And he
says, this is a quote, it's
burned into my brain: "After
that
concert"--and he was there,
I should say.
"After that concert,
everything looked different
in America as far as blacks
were concerned."
"After that concert,
everything looked different
in America as far as blacks
were concerned." Now
he's not talking literally,
because the day after
Marian Anderson sang,
it wasn't like if
you were black,
you could go into a local
restaurant that's not in the
black section of town,
or at Union Station,
the only other place
blacks could go for a public
restaurant. You couldn't go
in someplace else and get a
meal. You all of a sudden
couldn't get a job that was
denied to you, you know, the
week before. So in terms of
literal bread
and butter issues,
there's no change. But
at the level of symbolic
possibilities, at the
level of what blacks can
articulate and think
as maybe achievable,
fundamental change happens
with this concert. Now it's
also important because the
public outcry surrounding
Marian Anderson's concert is
happening in the context of
a larger battle of a war or
rhetoric against the Nazi
doctrines of racial
supremacy. So you can't
just understand this concert
in the context of an event
that happened in
Washington, D.C.,
or an event that happened in
the U.S. It's an event that
has global ramifications,
especially for the way in
which the U.S.
federal government is
struggling against a war of
words with Nazi and--Nazi
and fascist regimes. "The
U.S.
didn't have a
leg to stand on,
the Nazis would say,
"because they're just as
racist as we are." This is
very important for the U.S.
as it really does enter
the Second World War and
continues on
through the Cold War,
something I'll touch
down upon once or twice,
I'm sure, in this
course. As the U.S.
becomes an
international power,
which is this
part of the story,
the 1920s and thirties
and forties especially,
its domestic politics
become scrutinized much more
closely. World War II,
which we're on the cusp of
getting involved in, is a
war to stop the spread of
fascism, but if the U.S.
can't handle its own
fascistic tendencies
internal, it's a war of
hypocrisy. So you start
seeing there, in
the Scottsboro Boys,
reaching back to Monday,
and the way they use it as
cultural markers
for the Communists,
Marian Anderson being
used as a cultural marker of
democratic possibilities,
blacks being used as
cultural markers of
political possibilities,
of what this country
is supposed to be for
everybody, and what the
country's supposed to be for
African Americans, and what
the country's supposed to be
for the world. Now
this affords--oh,
one other, this is a
very famous image,
of course, of Marian
Anderson. There's another
image that I show up here
just for the sake of a,
a quick side lesson on how
you read images. There's a
way in which, you
know, we--we are,
in our minds' eye, we are
here sitting just below her
right shoulder, and we see
dignitaries at the micro--at
the, at the stand. This
image I dug up tells a very
different story. Except
for--I'll use the mouse
here--except for
this area here,
which is cordoned off for
reasons I honestly don't
know,
everything else you see,
except for that tree
line, going off to,
beyond the
Reflecting Pool, are people,
sitting there in an
integrated audience,
seventy-five thousand
people. It just sort of
gives you a different sense
of the way this might have
felt if you were actually
there. And because it's
harder to make out
Marian Anderson,
I'm as--I'm assuming that's
why this is not one of the
more famous iconic
pictures. You just,
here's just somebody's
back standing in front of an
audience. But it really was
quite a visual spectacle,
and I think offers ways for
you to think about how you
read images, for instance,
perspective being very
important. Now I was
talking before the little
caveat, I was talking about
political symbolism and the
roles and the ways in
which African Americans were
political footballs. And
then I wanted to transition
to a story that helps us
understand how blacks start
using this to their great
advantage and that's the
story of A.
Philip Randolph. A.
Philip Randolph, whose name
has come up several times
already in the course, and
I'm going to devote the rest
of the lecture
to him quickly,
he is one of the most
important transitional
political figures in
African American history.
He was born in 1889,
dies in 1979. I mean,
the ranges of what happens
in his lifetime is really
astonishing. But here's a
person who's involved in the
political scene in the
nineteen-teens and twenties,
taking a frontline argument
on issues. And he's there
in 1941 at a moment
of, of powerful symbolic
importance, I'll be talking
about in a moment. And he's
there in 1963 when King
steps up to the microphone
and delivers his
"Dream" speech. Incredibly
important political person.
Helps us navigate from a
period of Booker T.
Washington political power,
ideology of accommodation,
and through his consistent
socialist politics--Randolph
couldn't stand
Communists but was an ardent
Socialist--transitions
African American political
voice to a very different
kind--different kind of
voice. Now there's three
phases to Randolph's career
through 1941. In 1914,
he moves to New York City,
becomes witness, well part
of and witness to the Great
Migration and sees the
way it transforms that
particular urban site.
He sees the NAACP and the
National Urban League as
people--organizations
fighting out for
resources--fighting
over resources,
certainly affecting workers'
lives by their policies,
but not really at the
workers' level. NAACP being
very much a
top-down organization,
with assimilationist and
middle-class norms. The
National Urban League
trying to help people on the
ground, but, you
know, in the pocket of
corporate--corporations and
helping basically break up
labor unions.
And Randolph says,
"But what about the workers
themselves?" And so he
starts looking around
for different ways to get
involved in
workers' movements,
labor movements. In
1917, he declares himself a
Socialist, urges
blacks to resist the U.S.
draft and to confine their
fighting to the domestic
front. He can't stand
Du Bois's call to close
our--close ranks. And
around the same time he,
along with another black
socialist named Chandler
Owen, start publishing a
mess--a magazine called the
Messenger.
Through the Messenger,
Randolph calls for a bold,
black socialist leadership,
calls for radicals who would
not be afraid to challenge
accepted notions
of, of how a U.S.
society should operate. If
Washington is on this part
of a spectrum, and Du Bois
is over here on the opposite
side, Randolph's even
further beyond Du Bois
politically. He and
Owen are characterized as
Bolsheviks by
members of Congress.
They're investigated by
the Department of Justice,
and they
declare in response,
"We would be glad to see
a Bolshevik government
substituted in the South
in place of your Bourbon,
reactionary, vote-stolen,
misrepresentative,
democratic
regime." That sounds like,
you know, Black
Panther talking here,
doesn't it? In 1919,
Randolph says that he's
thankful for the
Russian Revolution,
the greatest achievement of
the twentieth century. But
when the American
version--when the American
Communist Party is
organized in twenty-one,
Randolph remains a Socialist
and dedicates the rest of
his life really
to preventing
social--Communists from
controlling or representing
black America. By
the mid-twenties,
the Messenger as a journal
is actually not doing that
well. Randolph still
casting about for ways in
which to connect
with black workers,
and a labor union is
being--is organized,
and recognized that Randolph
really has the voice that
they need to be heard in
a larger--a larger scene,
and that's the Brotherhood
of Sleeping Car Porters and
Maids. In '25, 1925,
Randolph's recruited to head
the union of
Sleeping Car Porters,
and then when organized,
trying to get the American
Federation--the
Pullman Company,
people who run the
trains, own the trains,
to recognize that union, and
then the American Federation
of Labor to recognize that
union. Efforts are made to
get better working
conditions and higher wages
from Pullman. Pullman
refuses both and tries
blackballing
Randolph, tries to,
you know, crush him.
Randolph becomes very
unpopular with black and
white groups alike for his
radical stances, but the
Brotherhood of Sleeping Car
Porters does earn
the--gather the support of
the NAACP, the Urban League,
and eventually the American
Federation of Labor. It
wins partial recognition in
1926, and in 1929,
more recognition,
but still not full
recognition. A decade later
after starting this battle,
Randolph does win for the
Brotherhood of Sleeping
Car Porters and Maids full
recognition
from the AFL and,
a year later, from the
Pullman Porters--the Pullman
porters--I mean
from the AFL,
ex--from the Pullman
Company. The wages go up,
job security goes
up, benefits go up.
The Pullman porters actually
become a great vehicle to
attain middle-class status
for a segment of black
America.
In fact, the
Pullman porters,
the U.S.
post, the military, over
the course of the twentieth
century, are the three great
ways for black Americans to
transition to middle-class
status. With Randolph's
victories with the
Brotherhood of Sleeping Car
Porters and Maids getting
fully recognized finally in
'36 and '37, he is
seen as, without doubt,
the most important
black labor leader in the
country. This is why he's
selected to run the National
Negro Congress. There's
nobody else who has his
access, who has his power,
and his influence. But as
you know, Randolph is a
staunch anti-Communist,
and as the National Negro
Congress develops further,
he realizes there's no place
for him any more in that
organization. So Randolph
starts thinking of a
different way to
achieve justice for blacks,
full citizenship rights and
decent jobs for blacks in
the United States. The
National Negro Congress is
not going to be the
vehicle. What Randolph sees
is that as the U.S.
war industry
starts to develop,
as it's arming
Europe--Western Europe,
or the Allies, I
should say--as the U.S.
war machine, industrial
war machine develops,
these are the best
paying jobs in the country,
as far as, you know,
factory work is concerned,
and blacks can't get those
jobs. They can work--they
can push a broom
in the factory,
but they can't roll steel,
or whatever you do in a
munitions factory.
Factories run overtime.
There's money to be made
hand over fist. Blacks
couldn't get those jobs.
There's movements being made
to increase the
size of the army,
a powerfully segregated
army. Randolph says,
"Where do we fit
in, in all of this?
We're second-class in
the factory and in the
military." Randolph and a
group of other leaders go to
Franklin Roosevelt,
September of 1940,
with a seven
point plan, that,
I mean, I'm not going to go
into now in the interests of
time, but
essentially calling for the
desegregation or the
integration of the U.S.
military, calling for access
to all jobs in the defense
industries, essentially
anti-discrimination
policies. The plea
is ignored. FDR,
always being afraid of
losing his coalition of
southern Democrats who would
be upset by any sort of
racial progressive
politics. Blacks are going
into the army certainly, but
they're going into all black
units, trained in
separate places,
trained most often by white
officers. A lot of the same
story that you heard in
World War I. Domestic
hiring situation is a joke.
Blacks are not being hired
in factory floor jobs. As
white men go off to fight in
the war, white women are
brought into the factory,
a radical change for
women's possibilities,
certainly, but black men and
black women are not getting
these jobs. So in
January of 1941,
Randolph proposes--I mean
he's no longer with the
National Negro Congress.
He's broken from them. He
proposes a March
on Washington,
and he demands that
something be done regarding
black access to jobs, and of
course for the integration
of the military. And he
calls at first for ten
thousand blacks to march on
Washington. And as that met
with enthusiasm, he calls
for fifty thousand. Then he
calls for one hundred
thousand blacks to march on
Washington that
summer, on July 1st,
if there is no change. It
doesn't seem like bluster.
Things have changed, on the
ground and in the air. As
we head into the
summer, into June,
people in D.C.
are getting
concerned. "My god,
what if one hundred thousand
Negroes come into this city
and are angry? What
are we going to do?" And
Roosevelt,
Franklin Roosevelt,
dispatches two of his
most trusted sort of network
political
operatives to talk with A.
Philip Randolph to calm him
down. He sends Fiorello La
Guardia, then the
mayor of New York City,
liberal on race issues.
"Please talk to Randolph and
tell him to call off this
march." No dice. He sends
his wife, the most powerful
proponent on these issues in
his pocket, he sends
his wife. Randolph goes,
"No dice. I'm not, I'm
not canceling this march."
Finally FDR says,
"Okay, Mr. Randolph,
come to see me."It's a week
before the march is set to
go off. Randolph goes
into the White House,
meets with Roosevelt.
And Roosevelt says,
Roosevelt says, "If
you call off the march,
I'll issue an executive
order with 'teeth' in it,
as the word was.
And Randolph says,
"Okay." Roosevelt signs
Executive Order 8802 on June
25th, 1941. It says there
shall be no discrimination
in the employment of workers
in defense industries or
government
because of race, creed,
color or national origin,
and it's the duty of the
employers and of labor
organizations to provide for
the full and equitable
participation of all workers
in defense industries
without discrimination based
on race, creed, color,
national origin. It sets up
a Fair Employment Practices
Committee that would be a
watchdog organization. It
couldn't do anything but
give bad publicity to a
factory that's not hiring
black workers. But
people didn't want to be,
to be seen
somehow as un-American,
so FE--FEPC could make some
changes along the margins,
along the edges of things.
You'll notice that the
executive order did not end
segregation in the military.
It's simply calling for
industry changes. Randolph
doesn't win that battle and
won't win it for a while.
Now blacks hail the
Executive Order 8802 as the
most significant order
since the Emancipation
Proclamation.
This is a new era,
and it's not a new era
just because of what the
President's calling
for. It's on the ground,
what happens is a little, a
little messier. It doesn't
immediately integrate all
industries. But what's
really important
is the linkage now,
the symbolic possibilities
and real political change,
and that is a prominent
leader of the African
American community called
the President's bluff;
was called into the White
House and they negotiated,
face to face, to find a
resolution. That's one of
the things, once the
genie's out of that bottle,
it can't go back in. So
black access to the White
House is now direct, to the
President. Presidents from
this point on cannot afford
to ignore black leaders in
the way they have been doing
since the founding of the
Republic. So you have in
A. Philip Randolph and the
March on Washington moment
the merging of the symbolic
politics of possibility
and the real politics of
possibility. And it is a
merger that would go on to
define the civil rights
movement that we know about
so well over the next thirty
or forty years. Thank you
very much.